PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE 14 FINALISTS MOVED INTO
THEIR NEW HOME IN LOS ANGELES.
MADE IT, TIFFANY!
WHEN I GAVE THE GIRLS
THE GIRLS MAKEOVERS,
SOME OF THEM
DEALT WITH THE PAIN,
WHILE KEENYAH AND BRANDY
WERE JUST A PAIN...
I CAN'T SEE MY EYEBROWS.
BUT IN THE END, THE JUDGES
FELT BRITA LACKED THE EDGE
OF A TOP MODEL,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
13 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
- TYRA MAIL.
- TYRA WHO?
- TYRA WHAT?
- MAIL.
- OH, GOD, TIFFANY.
I'M SLEEPING.
COME ON.
"TODAY YOU'LL BATTLE
TO THE DEATH IN A COLISEUM.
BE READY AT 10 A.M."
WHOA!
ALL OF US GIRLS HAVE BEEN
GETTING ALONG,
JUST HAPPY-GO-LUCKY.
PEOPLE LOOK AT ME LIKE,
"SHE'S TOO SWEET,
SHE'S TOO NICE,"
BUT I WANT TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
I'M SURE AS HELL
GONNA GIVE IT MY ALL.
WHY IS THAT UP?
LET ME JUST BRUSH IT.
WHEN I MOVED INTO THE HOUSE,
I WASN'T TOO SURE ABOUT LIVING
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
IT DOES MAKE ME ANXIOUS.
DON'T CATCH THE EARRING.
I GET PARANOID ABOUT THAT.
IT HURTS YOUR EAR?
NO, I JUST GET PARANOID.
WITH MICHELLE,
THE SMALLEST THINGS
FREAK HER OUT.
MICHELLE GOT PROBLEMS.
TO BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO
DOES NOT FEEL GOOD AT ALL.
TYRA, SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT MY ATTITUDE.
HOW ARE YOU SLEEPIN'?
'CAUSE Y'ALL ARE TAKING LONG.
I THINK MY GREATEST OPPONENT
RIGHT NOW IS MYSELF.
TYRA MAIL SAID IT WOULD BE
A FIGHT TO THE DEATH
IN THE COLISEUM.
MAYBE WE'RE GONNA BE
DRESSED LIKE GLADIATORS.
WE ARE SUCH SPECULATORS,
WE'RE HORRIBLE.
WHAT THE HECK?
CHEERLEADERS.
OH, MY GOD.
I WAS LIKE WHAT?
I HATE CHEERLEADERS.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED
IS THREE MORE PRETTY GIRLS
TO ADD TO THE COLLECTION.
(cheers and applause)
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
YAY!
MISS J. WEARING
A CHEERLEADING OUTFIT
AND POM-POMS IN HIS HAIR
AND PIGTAILS.
HE LOOKED
REALLY CUTE, ACTUALLY.
MISS J. IS INVOLVED,
YOU KNOW THERE'S GONNA BE
WALKING INVOLVED.
GIRLS, YOU'RE HERE
FOR A CRASH COURSE
OF MISS J.'s RUNWAY TEACH.
HERE ARE PAIRS
OF PLATFORM CLOGS.
SO GRAB A PAIR AND MEET ME
ON THE FIELD, OKAY?
WORK IT OUT.
I JUST SAW A SHOW RECENTLY
WHERE A DESIGNER HAD THE GIRLS
WALKING IN A GARDEN.
THIS IS VERY, VERY DIFFICULT,
TO GET A GIRL WALKING ON GRASS
AND FEEL COMFORTABLE.
BAM.
THE GIRLS NEED TO HAVE
A PRESENCE.
HIT IT.
HEADS UP, TIFFANY,
HEADS UP.
I KNOW I'M GONNA FALL.
LOOK STRAIGHT AHEAD.
IT'S NOT EASY
WALKING ON GRASS, IS IT?
THERE'S A TRICK, AND THAT IS
TRY NOT TO MODEL.
PRESENCE.
♪♪♪
MICHELLE, YOU WALK LIKE
YOU HAVE SPINA BIFIDA
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF YOUR BODY.
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP UP,
BUT RELAX IT.
MICHELLE WALKS AS THOUGH SHE
HAS THE WORLD ON HER SHOULDERS.
KAHLEN, GET THE SHOULDER BACK
A BIT, BABY.
IF YOU DON'T PULL YOUR HEAD UP,
YOU'RE LIKE A MELTED CANDLE.
BRANDY, YOU'RE WALKING
A BIT LIKE THIS.
LEADING WITH HER CHIN,
THAT NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED.
NOT BAD, LLUVY,
NOT BAD, NOT BAD, NOT BAD.
TATIANA--
GIRL, TAKE LONGER STEPS.
SARAH, PICK IT UP.
SARAH WAS WALKING
QUITE HEAVY-FOOTED.
YOU SAY IT'S YOUR SHOE?
OKAY.
WALKING ON GRASS IN BIG,
CHUNKY BLACK CLOG SHOES,
IT DIDN'T GO SO GOOD FOR ME.
MISS FASHION VICTIM, I WANT
YOU TO BE ONE OF THE GOD'S
EXTRA SPECIAL CHILDREN
'CAUSE YOU NEED
THE HELP.
SOMEWHERE IN THIS
WONDERFUL STADIUM
IS A PAIR OF HIGH HEELS
FOR EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU.
ALL UP HERE?
THE STADIUM WAS HUGE.
I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY HUGE!
I NEED YOU TO HAVE
THOSE SHOES IN YOUR HAND
AND THEN ON YOUR FEET.
ON THE COUNT OF THREE.
ONE, TWO, THREE!
♪♪♪
SCAVENGER HUNT,
SCAVENGER
HUNT, SCAVENGER HUNT.
I DON'T SEE ANY SHOES!
WHERE THE... ARE THEY?
WE DON'T SEE ANY SHOES.
WE DON'T SEE ANY SHOES,
WHERE ARE THE SHOES?
OH, MY GOSH,
WHERE ARE THE SHOES.
I JUST LOOK UP, AND I SEE
ALL 13 PAIRS OF SHOES.
WHEN I CALL YOUR A NAME,
YOU'LL BE GIVEN AN ACCESSORY.
THE MOST DIFFICULT THING
FOR A GIRL TO UNDERSTAND
IS THAT YOU NEED TO GO OUT THERE
AND REALLY PRESENT THE CLOTHES
IN DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
THE KEY TO WALKING WITH
A REALLY HUGE ACCESSORY
IS TO GIVE IT YOUR BEST SHOT,
BUT NOT NECESSARILY TO GIVE
THAT OVER-THE-TOP
RUNWAY STOMP.
AND IT'S ALWAYS A SURPRISE
WHEN GIRLS HAVE TO WALK
DOWN STEPS.
AND I'M GONNA DEMONSTRATE
HOW IT CAN BE DONE.
SO THESE ARE MY ACCESSORIES.
YOU KNOW,
I MAY WALK LIKE THIS.
♪♪♪
YOU GUYS ARE OKAY.
MISS BRANDY.
- OH, SHOOT.
- UH-HUH.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO BE TIED AND BEAT.
YEAH.
I FEEL LIKE I'M AT THE RACES
WITH THE TORTOISE AND THE HARE
AND, SARAH,
THAT YOU'RE THE TORTOISE.
BECKY!
RUNWAY IS MY FAVORITE PART
OF MODELING.
I'VE NEVER REALLY HAD
FORMAL TRAINING,
BUT I DO STILL FEEL CONFIDENT
IN RUNWAY,
SO I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE BEST RUNWAY COACH
IN THE WORLD
IS GONNA TELL ME.
I THINK BECKY FEELS
QUITE CONFIDENT
WITH A LOT
OF HAIR ON HER HEAD.
♪♪♪
OKAY, GIRL,
STILL WITH ELEGANCE.
BRITTANY REMINDS ME
OF JANICE DICKINSON.
SHE NEEDS TO BRING IT DOWN
A LEVEL.
J. SAID THAT I'M TOO SEXY,
I NEED TO TONE IT DOWN.
WHICH IS NICE,
AT LEAST IT'S NOT,
"YOU'RE VERY AWKWARD."
OKAY, GIRLS,
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND PATIENCE.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO WALK
ON GRASS, PEBBLES, STEPS.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO WALK ON THINGS
LIKE THAT, TRY TO HAVE PRESENCE.
THANK YOU.
SEE YOU GIRLS LATER, OKAY?
BRAVO.
♪♪♪
DON'T FORGET THE FIRST DRILL
THAT J. TAUGHT US WAS WALKING
IN A STRAIGHT LINE.
I LEFT THE COLISEUM FEELING
A LITTLE BAD ABOUT MY WALK.
KEENYAH HAS A VERY GOOD WALK,
SO I ASKED HER
TO GIVE ME SOME POINTERS.
LOOSEN UP RIGHT HERE.
SARAH--HER WALK
WAS, LIKE, TERRIBLE.
IT NEEDED A LOT OF WORK.
THAT WAS WAY TOO HARD.
YOU HAVE SO MUCH MOTION
IN THE OCEAN.
I FEEL LIKE I DON'T HAVE THAT,
YOU'RE ALL, LIKE...
YOU HAVE TO RELAX.
YOUR KNEE IS LIKE THIS.
CAN I SAY ONE THING
THAT I KINDA NOTICED?
THEY ALWAYS WANT YOU TO TAKE
WIDER STRIDES AND BEING SHORT,
WE HAVE TO TAKE--
IF YOU GIVE HER, LIKE,
FIVE TIPS AND SAY "PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER," IT'S HARD.
THIS IS STILL A COMPETITION,
SO I DIDN'T WANT TO, LIKE,
GIVE HER EVERYTHING
TO MAKE THEM CHOOSE HER OVER ME.
STEP WITH ME.
BAM, BAM, BAM,
BAM, BAM, BAM.
OH, MY GOD, SARAH.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH BETTER YOU ARE ALREADY.
YOU FEEL BETTER?
YEAH,
I FEEL REALLY CONFIDENT
WHEN I'M NEXT TO YOU.
IT'S RIDICULOUS HOW NICE
WE ARE TO EACH OTHER.
WE'RE OUTTA CONTROL.
IT'S LIKE--
WE'RE LIKE SISTERS.
IT'S CRAZY.
THIS IS NOT
AMERICA'S NEXT BEST FRIEND.
IT'S "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL."
GO, POSER!
KEEP IT SIMPLE.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS ARE POSIN' OFF,
ALL RIGHT?
LADIES, YOUR FIRST POSE
WE WANNA SEE IS ROCK STAR.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
OH! TATIANA!
(All taking at once)
THE COMPETITION IS GETTING
MORE FIERCE.
IT'S JUST, LIKE, BRINGING
MY CONFIDENCE DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
I'M TRYING TO CONNECT WITH
THE OTHER GIRLS, BUT, I MEAN,
IT'S HARD SOMETIMES.
HEY, WE GOT TYRA MAIL!
OH, YEAH.
OPEN IT AND READ IT.
"WHICH AISLE WILL HAVE
TODAY'S SPECIAL?
BE READY AT 6:45 A.M."
OH!
THAT'S EARLY.
I'M GETTING UP AT 5:00.
LET'S GO.
THAT'S BEFORE 7.
(alarm beeping)
WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT
TYRA MAIL.
AND WE NEVER GET IT RIGHT.
OH, MY GOD.
KMART.
YES.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE
SHOPPING SPOT.
KMART?
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
IN KMART?
WHAT IS WE GETTIN' INTO?
OH!
WE'RE PULLING UP
TO OUR MYSTERY LOCATION
FROM OUR TYRA MAIL,
AND WE SEE KMART.
THE LAST PLACE I THOUGHT
WE'D BE BE GOING WAS K-MART,
BUT, HEY,
I DON'T CARE, IT'S K-MART.
I'VE BEEN THERE
A MILLION TIMES.
♪♪♪
ATTENTION ALL SHOPPERS,
DUEL RUNWAY CHALLENGE
IN AISLES ONE AND TWO.
SO GOOD MORNING, GIRLS,
AND WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING.
A TOP MODEL CAN SELL
AN EVERYDAY ITEM
AS SOMETHING FABULOUS.
AND WHAT BETTER PLACE TO FIND
THINGS THAT YOU NEED EVERY DAY
THAN HERE?
WE LEARNED THE PREVIOUS DAY
HOW TO WALK WITH AN ACCESSORY.
KMART PROVIDES
ANY KIND OF ACCESSORY,
SO IT'S COMPLETELY FITTING.
TODAY I BROUGHT
MY YOUNG FRIEND SANDI BASS...
HELLO.
WHO IS ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL MODELS
FROM THE HOUSE OF GIVENCHY.
SHE HAS WORKED
WITH EVERY MAJOR DESIGNER.
YESTERDAY YOU HAD
A LITTLE RUNWAY CRASH COURSE.
AND TODAY, WE'RE GONNA
PUT THAT TO THE TEST.
THIS IS A CHALLENGE.
A DUEL RUNWAY CHALLENGE.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE DUELING
WITH EACH OTHER.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THERE CAN ONLY BE
ONE WINNER, OKAY?
SHALL WE GET STARTED?
YES.
SANDI?
HIT IT.
♪♪♪
YOU GUYS HAVE TO GO FASTER
THAN THIS, REALLY.
CHRISTINA AND BRITTANY
TO THE FRONT, PLEASE.
♪♪♪
YESTERDAY J. SAID THAT
I'M TOO SEXY.
HMM. LET ME SEE.
BYE, BRITTANY.
(buzzer)
AGAIN, TOO SEXY.
BRANDY'S WEARING
A FUCHSIA WRAP BLOUSE
AND A FRYING PAN.
HOW FABULOUS.
NAIMA IS WEARING
A FUCHSIA BLOUSE
AND A SPONGE MOP, MOP,
MOP, MOP AND FRY, FRY, FRY.
(buzzer)
MISS BRANDY, JUST STEP OVER HERE
TO MY RIGHT, PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
SIMPLE, SIMPLE, SIMPLE.
CHIC, CHIC, CHIC.
NOELLE, BYE.
(buzzer)
CAN I PLEASE
HAVE MICHELLE
OVER IN THE LAYAWAY
DEPARTMENT.
(buzzer)
- HOW YOU DOING?
- GOOD.
OKAY, GOOD.
KAHLEN'S WEARING A FUCHSIA
LONG SLEEVE BLOUSE AND A MOP.
IS THE MOP ON HER HEAD
OR IN HER HANDS?
LLUVY IS WEARING
BLACK CROPPED TEE
AND BLACK PLATFORMS
AND A BATH AND BOWL SCRUBBER.
LLUVY.
(buzzer)
TATIANA AND KEENYAH
TO SECURITY, PLEASE, THANK YOU.
TATIANA, TA-TA.
(buzzer)
SARAH WAS IN A WHOLE CATEGORY
BY HERSELF BECAUSE SHE'S SLOW.
SARAH, I NEED
SOME MORE SPUNK.
WALK AS THOUGH
YOU'RE WALKING THROUGH HELL
IN GASOLINE-SOAKED PAJAMAS.
UNFORTUNATELY,
WE DO NOT DO RETURNS
WITHOUT RECEIPTS.
THANK YOU.
(buzzer)
I JUST KIND OF FELT LIKE,
"OKAY, DAY TWO WITH MISS J.,
AND I'VE LEARNED
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING."
SO IT'S A LITTLE
NERVE-RACKING.
THIS IS GREAT
FOR THAT LEATHER SKIRT.
I LOVE IT.
CLADUMP. CLADUMP. CLADUMP.
KAHLEN.
(buzzer)
ATTENTION, TIFFANY,
THE SHOULDER BAG
SHOULD NOT BE HELD
AWAY FROM YOU AS THOUGH
YOU'RE CARRYING A DIRTY PAIR
OF UNDERWEAR.
THANK YOU.
(buzzer)
CAN WE PLEASE HAVE CHRISTINA
OVER IN LAYAWAY?
(buzzer)
KEENYAH, GO FIND
YOUR BABY'S DADDY.
(buzzer)
THE DUEL CHALLENGE FINAL
IS NOW TAKING PLACE
IN AISLES ONE AND TWO.
HIT IT.
I'M WALKING WITH REBECCA,
AND ALL I'M THINKING IS,
"THERE'S THIS BITCH NEXT TO ME,
AND IT'S EITHER HER OR IT'S ME,
AND IT'S GOT TO BE ME."
I AM REALLY FEELING
THE PRESSURE.
EVERYTHING I DO
IS A COMPETITION.
I ALWAYS WANT TO BE
THE BEST.
I HATE TO LOSE.
AND THE WINNER IS...
MISS BECKY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
TO KNOW THAT
THE BEST RUNWAY COACH
IN THE WORLD THINKS
THAT I'VE GOT A GOOD WALK...
I WAS THE WINNER.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHERE WE STAND,
AND I WAS AT THE TOP.
SO FOR TODAY'S WIN, YOU GET
TO MEET A FAMOUS SHOE DESIGNER,
AND YOU GET TO CHOOSE
FIVE FRIENDS TO GO WITH YOU.
FIVE FRIENDS?
MISS KAHLEN, MISS SARAH,
MISS NOELLE, MISS LLUVY.
LAST ONE,
WHO IS IT GOING TO BE?
I'M GONNA PICK NAIMA
BECAUSE SHE WAS DAMN CLOSE.
SHE WAS A HARD COMPETITOR.
FOR THE GIRLS
WHO DIDN'T MAKE
THIS WONDERFUL LINE OVER HERE,
YOU GET TO SERVICE THE GIRLS.
- SERVICE?
- SERVICE.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING WORD.
SERVE THEM?
WHAT IS THIS?
I THOUGHT
I DID PRETTY GOOD.
WHY SHOULD I HAVE TO
SERVE ANYBODY?
I THINK
THEY SHOULD BE SERVING ME.
OKAY, GIRLS, THANK YOU.
(applause)
GREAT JOB.
♪♪♪
I'M REALLY, REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT MEETING THE SHOE DESIGNER.
WE DON'T KNOW
WHO IT IS YET.
OH, MY GOSH!
THOSE ARE SICK.
♪♪♪
STUART WEITZMAN'S SHOES
ARE GORGEOUS.
OH, MY GOSH.
TO JUST LOOK AROUND HIS STORE
JUST GETS MY HEART
BEATING A LITTLE FASTER.
WELCOME TO SHOE HEAVEN.
I AM STUART WEITZMAN.
AND, REBECCA,
YOU GET TO PICK OUT
A BEAUTIFUL PAIR OF SHOES
AND FIVE OF YOUR FRIENDS
ALSO GET TO PICK OUT
A BEAUTIFUL PAIR OF SHOES...
WHILE THE REST OF YOU LADIES,
YOU'RE GONNA SERVE THEM
AND TREAT THEM LIKE THE QUEENS
THAT THEY WILL BE
WHEN THEY WEAR THESE SHOES.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
SOME OF THOSE GIRLS
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
THEY DID NOT EVEN WALK
THAT GOOD.
AND HERE THEY ARE GETTING
A BRAND-NEW PAIR OF SHOES,
AWESOME LIKE...
IT WAS JUST WRONG.
JAY, WHY DON'T YOU TAKE
THE UNLUCKY LADIES
AND SHOW WHERE
THE STOCK ROOM IS.
AND IT'S A GOOD THING
SOME OF YOU ARE IN JEANS.
YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE VERY,
VERY CAREFUL
THAT THERE'S NO ONE IN HERE.
- OKAY.
- AND THEN YOU JUST PULL IT.
I DIDN'T LIKE THE THING
THEY KEPT THE SHOES IN.
MY ONE WORST FEAR
IS BEING, LIKE, SQUISHED.
THE SHOES
ARE ACCORDING TO COLORS
AND THEY'RE ALPHABETIZED.
THAT'S WHY YOU MUST KNOW
THE NAME OF THE SHOE.
I HOPE
I DON'T COME DOWNSTAIRS
AND EVERY GIRL HAS, LIKE,
30 PAIRS OF SHOES AND ARE LIKE,
"GO GET A 9 1/2
IN EACH OF THESE."
♪♪♪
IN OKLAHOMA, WE DO HAVE SHOES,
BUT NOTHING LIKE THIS.
STUART WEITZMAN--
WE WERE GONNA GET TO TAKE
A PAIR OF THOSE SHOES HOME.
OH, MY GOD.
ALL OF US, TEARS IN OUR EYES.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
THIS IS THE BEST DAY
OF MY LIFE.
THIS IS AMAZING.
THIS IS LIKE A CINDERELLA STORY.
I AM GLAD I'M NOT
ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT ARE HAVING TO SERVE US.
DID SOMETHING BAD HAPPEN?
NO, I WAS IN THERE
AND SOMEONE WAS CLOSING IT
AND IT SCARED THE... OF ME.
MICHELLE, YOU DON'T NEED
TO BE OVER HERE, SERIOUSLY.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO, SERIOUSLY, YOU'VE ALREADY
HAD A BAD EXPERIENCE.
I DON'T CARE,
IF YOU GUYS JUST--
I CAN DO IT IF THEY DON'T
DO THAT AGAIN AT ALL.
MICHELLE--SHE WALKS
INSIDE HER SHOE SHELVES,
AND SHE'S LIKE,
"I'M GOING INSIDE HERE
SO NOBODY CLOSE IT."
AND I LEAN IN
LIKE I'M GOING TO CLOSE IT,
BARELY, AND, LIKE,
TOUCH THE KNOB,
AND I GUESS SHE JUST HEARD
THE SHELF MOVE,
AND SHE WENT CRAZY.
I TOLD YOU I WAS IN HERE,
AND I KNOW YOU WERE PLAYING,
BUT YOU STILL DID IT.
I JUST DON'T--DON'T DO IT AGAIN
AND I'LL BE FINE.
IT'S JUST...
MICHELLE, SHE'S USUALLY
VERY QUIET AND SOFT.
AND WE WERE LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL IS THIS?
- WHERE'S MICHELLE?"
- YOU WAS JUST PLAYING.
I REALLY, SERIOUSLY WAS.
IT WAS JUST LIKE THIS.
- IT DIDN'T EVEN MOVE.
- IT WAS JUST LIKE THIS.
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHY SHE FLIPPED LIKE THAT.
THAT WAS CRAZY.
LITERALLY, IT WAS NUTS.
I KIND OF FEEL
THAT WALL BUILDING
BETWEEN MYSELF
AND THE OTHER GIRLS.
WHEN I'M AT A LOW POINT,
YOU KNOW, FREAKING OUT
OR STRESSED OUT,
I HATE SHOWING THAT TO PEOPLE.
I HATE WHEN PEOPLE SEE THAT.
TIME TO GET THE SHOES,
HALLELUJAH.
TIME TO GET TO WORK.
READY?
HERE WE GO.
BYE, SISTER.
I THINK I'M GOING, TOO.
HI, MY NAME IS MICHELLE.
HOW MAY I BE OF SERVICE?
MICHELLE--
SO HAPPY ONE MINUTE,
THEN IT'S JUST LIKE
MICHELLE SNAPS,
AND HER MIND JUST CUTS OFF
AND THEN SHE'S BACK TO,
"OH, I'M BUBBLY."
MICHELLE IS CRAZY.
I WOULD LIKE PEGGY SUE.
THE METEORIC.
WHAT KIND OF SHOES WILL YOU
BE TRYING ON TODAY?
THIS IS MARRY ME, SIZE 9.
RAMBLING ROSE.
OH, IN GOLD.
AND METEORIC IN GOLD.
NEXT SHOE.
RIBBON AIR.
BECCA'S ATTITUDE
WAS VERY SNOOTY.
ALL OF US FELT IT,
NONE OF US LIKED IT.
ARE YOU SATISFIED?
I'M WONDERFUL,
THANK YOU.
- ARE YOU SURE?
- MM-HMM.
ARE YOU SURE THAT YOU'RE
SURE THAT YOU'RE SURE?
I'M TRYING TO BE
A GRACIOUS WINNER.
I CAN'T WORRY ABOUT
EVERYONE ELSE'S FEELINGS.
I WORKED MY BUTT OFF
ON THE RUNWAY, AND I'M GONNA
ENJOY EVERY SINGLE MINUTE
OF THIS.
OH, NO, I DROPPED
A STRAWBERRY LEAF IN MY WATER.
CAN I HAVE SOME MORE?
HONESTLY, FROM THE HEART,
THEY MADE US FEEL LIKE CRAP.
IT'S MY BIGGEST CHALLENGE
TO WORK ON MY ATTITUDE
AND NOT SAY ANYTHING TO ANYBODY,
BUT I'M IRRITATED.
Y'ALL DONE MADE ME MAD.
MISS REBECCA.
- HELLO, YOU GOT MY SHOES?
- YES, I DO.
THESE ARE MADE
SO THAT YOU CAN TIE THEM
TWO WAYS, AND I WOULD SAY 8 1/2
MIGHT BE BETTER FOR YOU.
I THINK EVERY GIRL
IS A LITTLE JEALOUS
THAT THEY DIDN'T GET
A PAIR OF SHOES.
THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
I CAN'T CHOOSE EVERYBODY.
YOU ARE A GENIUS.
MISS REBECCA.
SO HOW ABOUT,
LIKE, A BIG HUG?
OH!
STUART HUGGED ALL OF THEM
AND WAS, LIKE,
"OH, GOOD LUCK, GIRLS,
CONGRATULATIONS."
WE'RE JUST
THESE HUGE LOSERS WHO STUNK.
IT JUST WASN'T
A FRIENDLY FEELING.
I CAN FEEL
A LITTLE BIT MORE TENSION.
I THINK THERE REALLY IS A LINE
THAT'S STARTING TO BE DRAWN.
THIS IS COMPETITION
AND I'M SORRY,
BUT I'M NOT HERE TO FEED
YOUR EGO,
I'M HERE FOR ME.
BRANDY, I'MA NEED YOU
TO KNOW, WE'VE GOT TYRA MAIL.
MICHELLE'S
IN THE OTHER ROOM.
MICHELLE JUST REALLY STAYS AWAY
FROM EVERYBODY A LOT.
"CAN YOU WORK
WITH TEN OTHER BITCHES?
BE READY AT 7:15."
SHUT UP, TEN GIRLS
FROM THE LAST SEASONS?
OH, YEAH.
MICHELLE IS GETTING
VERY WEIRD.
SHE SEEMS TO BLOW UP
ON PEOPLE RANDOMLY.
I WENT TO MICHELLE'S ROOM
TO CONFRONT HER
ABOUT HER ATTITUDE.
ME AND TIFFANY, WE HEAR
MICHELLE SAYING SOMETHING,
AND THEN
WE START EAVESDROPPING,
TRYING TO SEE EXACTLY
WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT.
YEAH, BECAUSE I'VE BEEN,
LIKE, HIDING IT FOR SO LONG.
I MEAN,
IT'S EATING ME UP INSIDE
BECAUSE I CAN'T GET IT OUT.
I THINK THE REASON
I WAS RELUCTANT TO,
LIKE, TELL EVERYONE IS
BECAUSE HOW PEOPLE WOULD REACT.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THAT
EVERY SINGLE GIRL IN THIS HOUSE
IS NOT GOING TO LOOK AT YOU
A STITCH DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE YOU'RE BI.
I HEARD HER SAY, "I'M GAY,"
YOU KNOW,
SO I WAS LIKE, "WHAT?"
♪♪♪
I THINK THE REASON
I WAS RELUCTANT TO, LIKE,
TELL EVERYONE IS BECAUSE
HOW PEOPLE WOULD REACT.
MICHELLE AND NOELLE
WERE IN THE ROOM TALKING,
AND I WAS EAVESDROPPING TILL
I HEARD HER SAY, "I'M GAY."
YOU KNOW,
SO I WAS LIKE, "WHAT?"
NO, I DON'T KNOW. YOU GAY?
SHE'S BI.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT.
SHE FEELS LIKE SHE'S HAD TO
HIDE THIS FOR SO LONG.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTED.
YOU THINK ABOUT ME?
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH BISEXUALITY.
I THINK MICHELLE JUST NEEDS
TO KNOW WE'RE GONNA ACCEPT HER
EITHER WAY.
SO HOW DO YOU KNOW
YOU LIKE A GIRL?
HOW DO YOU KNOW?
MY FIRST RELATIONSHIP
WITH ANOTHER WOMAN,
AND THE FIRST TIME WE KISSED,
WE SAT THERE AND WE'RE LIKE...
EW. OH NO.
UM, NO.
AND, I MEAN, SHE'S LIKE,
"YOU KNOW,
THAT WASN'T THAT BAD,"
AND I WAS LIKE,
"NO, ACTUALLY IT WASN'T."
MICHELLE'S OUTBURSTS
MAKE A LOT MORE SENSE TO ME
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO HIDE A PART OF WHO YOU ARE,
YOU'RE BOUND
TO HAVE FREAK-OUTS.
MICHELLE, THE BEST THING
FOR YOU TO DO IS TELL IT.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT THEY
ALL JUST CAME TOGETHER FOR ME
AND ACCEPTED ME.
I JUST FEEL MORE CONFIDENT
AND I FEEL LIKE I CAN JUST BE
MYSELF NOW.
YOU'RE OKAY?
YEAH, I'M GOOD. I'M GOOD.
I'M A LOT BETTER NOW.
YOU'RE GAY. OH.
YEAH. YEP!
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT WORKING WITH
TEN OTHER BITCHES.
I'M LIKE, "I ALREADY GOT
TO WORK WITH THESE BITCHES."
I DON'T NEED NO MORE.
♪♪♪
ON TODAY'S SHOOT DOING HAIR--
FABULOUS, FAMOUS DANILO.
WITH MAKEUP,
WE HAVE MR. MATTHEW,
WHO CAN PAINT ANYTHING.
WARDROBE STYLIST
FOR ALL YOUR SHOOTS--Q.
SHE'S GOT YOU ALL DOWN.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
FOR TODAY IS DANIELLE.
HI!
THIS SHOOT
IS FOR 1-800-FLOWERS.
WE'RE GONNA START YOU GUYS
INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND THEN YOUR CO-STARS
ARE SHOWING UP.
LET'S GET TO WORK.
♪♪♪
I LOVE IT LONG.
I'M JUST STILL TRYING
TO GET USED TO HOW TO DO IT.
I'M REALLY FEELING
THE PRESSURE OF THE SHOOT.
THIS IS WHAT IT'S
ALL ABOUT.
THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GETTING JUDGED ON.
MAKE TYRA PROUD.
(horn honking)
(squealing and screaming)
I'M HERE. HI, GIRLS.
HI.
WELCOME TO THE LOVELY
GRIFFITH PARK.
THIS IS THE PARK THAT I USED
TO GO, OKAY,
WITH MY LITTLE BOYFRIEND.
WHO CAN GUESS NOW
WHAT THE TYRA MAIL... MEANS?
YOU GUYS HAVE TO BE POSING
WITH TEN DOGGIES TODAY!
(cheering)
YOU GUYS WILL BE
WALKING THESE DOGS,
CARRYING FLOWERS
AND LOOKING FIERCE!
WHILE WE HAVE THIS GORGEOUS
MALE MODEL IN THE BACKGROUND.
(screaming)
WE'RE GONNA
HAVE FUN TODAY.
YEAH.
BYE, GUYS.
BYE!
I NEED FIERCE,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WORK IT. NOTHING HOOCHIE,
NOT LIKE YOU AT A SHOW PALACE.
- OH, NOT LIKE THAT.
- YEAH, NOT LIKE THAT.
IF THE DOG BITE ME,
I'M BITING THEM BACK.
YEAH, RIGHT THERE.
YOU CAN GRAB THE FLOWERS.
LIKE, YOU COULD BE LIKE THIS,
LIKE, "OOH, OKAY,
PAPA'S BACK THERE,
HE'S CHECKING ME OUT."
THAT'S THE POINT.
UH-HUH,
BUT WITHOUT THE GHETTO FACE.
- GOOD!
- THERE YOU GO.
NOW YOU'RE GIVING ME
TOP MODEL.
- WAS IT EASY?
- YOU LOOK REALLY PRETTY.
HELL NO, IT WASN'T EASY!
THAT'S WHAT
I WANTED TO KNOW.
YOU'RE STANDING
WITH THE DOGS,
BUT TRUST ME,
THEY CAN MOVE YOU.
CHRISTINA,
I STILL NEED SOME RANGE.
STRAIGHTEN THE FACE OUT!
WORK YOUR FACE.
CHRISTINA, WHEN SHE EXTENDS
HER NECK AND HER EYES,
THERE'S TOO MUCH TENSION
CREATED IN HER FACE.
I FEEL LIKE MARILYN.
THE FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
I GOT "TOO PORN STAR,"
SO THIS SHOOT, I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE IT WAS
MORE HIGH FASHION
AND NOT MORE SLUTTY.
BRITTANY--SHE'S STILL
GETTING A LITTLE BIT OF THIS
PORNO KIND-OF-MOVEMENT
THING GOING ON.
LOOK AT THEM!
THEY'RE SO CUTE!
I'M GONNA NEED YOU
NOT TO SCRATCH THE FLEAS.
COME ON, BABY,
PULL THOSE DOGS IN.
THEY'RE RUNNING YOU.
YEAH. SEXY. GREAT.
BRANDY LOOKED REALLY GREAT.
I THINK THAT HER SHOT
WAS VERY DYNAMIC.
WHOA!
A LITTLE BIT TENSE.
NO, NO, NO,
YOU WANT TO GO FORWARD.
YOU DON'T WANT TO
LEAN BACK.
YOUR EXPRESSION NEEDS TO ALTER
A LITTLE BIT.
KEENYAH HAD
A BIT OF A STRUGGLE.
SHE WAS UNABLE TO WORK THE DOG,
HER FACIAL EXPRESSION
AND HER BODY.
GO. STRONGER. TALLER.
UP. UP, UP, UP, UP.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY
YOUR LEGS HAVE TO BE PLANTED.
IT'S NOT CEMENT.
NAIMA WAS A LITTLE TOUGH.
SHE DIDN'T SEEM TO COMMAND
HER EXPRESSIONS
AS WELL AS SHE COULD HAVE.
CHIN DOWN. STRAIGHTEN UP.
SEXY. KEEP WORKING.
GOOD! STRONG.
TATIANA REALLY
IMPRESSED ME TODAY.
SHE HANDLED THE DOGS
AND HERSELF AND THOSE FLOWERS.
LAST NIGHT I GOT
A BUNCH OF STUFF OFF MY CHEST,
AND I FEEL
SO MUCH BETTER NOW.
HOPEFULLY IT HAS AN EFFECT
ON THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND THE JUDGES SEE
I'M MORE CONFIDENT.
YOU LOOK GORGEOUS,
BY THE WAY.
YEAH, THROW THAT HEAD BACK.
KEEP MOVING.
MICHELLE!
DAMN, GIRL,
THAT'S THE WAY TO OWN A SET.
MICHELLE WAS
A WONDERFUL MODEL.
SHE IS INCREDIBLY
STATUESQUE.
SHE'S GOT
WONDERFUL FEATURES.
I LOVE IT. GORGEOUS.
YOU OWNING IT, MAMA.
LLUVY DOES NOT HAVE
A CONVENTIONAL SORT OF BEAUTY
THAT THE OTHER GIRLS HAVE,
AND I LOVE HOW FOCUSED SHE WAS.
TRY NOT TO HOLD THE FLOWERS
LIKE YOU'RE ON A PAGEANT.
BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE LIKE,
"HI, I WON MISS AMERICA."
I DON'T FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE CONNECTING.
THIS IS WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE--
"(imitating drawl)
HI, I'M WALKING SOME DOGS."
(normal voice)
SARAH IS ACTING LIKE
A PIECE OF DRIFTWOOD.
SHE'S TOTALLY FORGETTING
THERE'S A HOT GUY
STANDING OVER HER SHOULDER.
CHIN DOWN. STRONGER!
- I'M SORRY.
- THAT'S OKAY.
NOELLE WENT AFTER ME.
SHE SAID,
"WHAT SHOULD I EXPECT?"
AND I WAS LIKE, "NOBODY TOLD ME
ANYTHING WHAT TO EXPECT."
I'M NOT TELLING YOU ANYTHING
EITHER, I'M SORRY.
IT'S A COMPETITION.
CHIN DOWN. FACE OUT.
LITTLE MORE FACE.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE YOU
TRY AND MODEL.
GOT IT.
IT JUST LOOKS AWKWARD.
NOELLE REALLY WANTED TO MAKE
THE PICTURE WORK.
I THINK
IT WAS DIFFICULT THOUGH.
GIRL, COME ON,
I GOT THAT ONE, KEEP MOVING IT.
FLOWERS ARE LOOKING
A LITTLE FUNNY,
LIKE YOU'VE GOT A BAGUETTE.
LOOK AT ME, KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, WORKING
WITH THE DOGS AND FLOWERS--
SHE KEPT POPPING OUT
HER BUTT.
I WANT YOU TO FEEL THE GUY
CHECKING YOU OUT
OVER YOUR SHOULDER.
YOU'VE GOT THE FLOWERS
IN THE HAND,
THE DOG IN THE OTHER.
SO I NEED YOU TO GET
INTO THE ROLE FOR ME.
THAT'S YOUR INTERNAL
DIALOGUE.
I THINK I CAN DO THIS.
STOP LOOKING SO NICE.
YEAH, WORK THAT.
STRONG, STRAIGHT UP.
YEAH, YOU'RE MY NEW GIRL,
COME ON.
REBECCA COMES OUT
WITH HER PREPPY LITTLE LOOK,
AND THEN SHE TURNS IT OUT
AND LOOKED INCREDIBLE
IN THE CAMERA.
THERE WAS QUITE A FEW GIRLS
AT MY SHOOT.
IT'S THE MOST PRESSURE
I'VE EVER FELT,
BUT I'M HERE FOR A REASON.
I'M HERE TO WIN.
ALL RIGHT. YEAH!
YOU'RE MY NEW GIRL.
I LOVE IT!
♪♪♪
- WE GOT TYRA MAIL!
- THERE'S TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 12 OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.'
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
I'M NOT LOOKING AT THAT
RIGHT NOW.
EVERYBODY IS A LITTLE MORE
NERVOUS THIS TIME.
I'M NOT GOING TO
SUGARCOAT IT.
IF THEY'RE STILL
JUST GOING ON PHOTOS,
THEN I THINK I'LL DO FINE.
BUT IF WALKING COMPETITIONS,
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT,
THEN IT'S NOT LOOKING
TOO GOOD FOR ME.
♪♪♪
THAT'S A LOT BETTER,
THAT'S A LOT BETTER.
SLOWING IT DOWN
HELPS YOU A LOT.
I HONESTLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT IS GONNA HAPPEN
AT ELIMINATION.
I AM CONFIDENT IN MYSELF,
BUT I WISH I KNEW
WHO WAS GOING HOME.
BUT I DON'T, SO IT MAKES IT
JUST SO TOUGH TO WALK
INTO THAT ROOM.
♪♪♪
IT IS TIME TO MAKE
OUR SECOND CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE SOME FABULOUS PRIZES--
A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL MODELING
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER GILLES BENSIMON
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
WE HAVE SOME VERY OPINIONATED
JUDGES, STARTING WITH
THE MOST OPINIONATED ONE,
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS.
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
Hi, LADIES.
NOLE MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
HELLO, LADIES.
IN PERSON, MIMI'S HERE.
HI, MIMI!
AND OUR SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE
SANDI BASS.
HELLO, LADIES.
HI. HI, SANDI.
SANDI IS THE MUSE OF GIVENCHY
AND A MODEL SCOUT.
THIS WEEK,
YOU'RE GONNA BE EVALUATED
ON WHAT MISS J. TAUGHT YOU
ABOUT FIERCE RUNWAY WALKING.
YOU WILL BE GIVEN THIS...
50-CENT POTATO SACK,
AND IT IS UP TO YOU
TO MAKE THIS POTATO SACK LOOK
LIKE A $20,000 COUTURE GOWN.
AND, REBECCA,
YOU ARE FIRST, DARLING.
♪♪♪
WORK IT OUT.
OH, SORRY.
LOOK, GOT MY NEW SHOES ON.
JUST WALK, SARAH.
(laughing)
GO, GIRL!
YEAH, SHE MADE IT.
ALL RIGHTY.
FIRST IS REBECCA.
I THOUGHT THAT YOUR WALK
WAS, YOU KNOW, GOOD,
CONFIDENT, STRONG.
I THINK YOU KIND OF FORGOT
WHAT TYRA'S DIRECTIONS WERE.
IT DIDN'T LOOK EXPENSIVE.
IT READ BURLAP TO ME.
YOU HAD A PHOTO
IN GRIFFITH PARK,
AND YOU HAD TO SELL FLOWERS,
AND YOU HAD TO HANDLE TEN DOGS.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
OH, CUTE, CUTE, CUTE.
OVERALL, I THINK IT'S
A GREAT, GREAT SHOT.
THE DOGS LOOK GREAT,
YOU LOOK GREAT.
KIND OF LOOKS, LIKE,
A LITTLE SLUTTY THOUGH,
LIKE, REAL '40s PINUP,
I'M DIGGING IT.
I THINK YOU HAVE EVERYTHING
TOGETHER FOR A MODEL.
YOU NEED TO WORK
ON YOUR PRESENCE.
I DIDN'T FEEL
THAT YOU EMBRA--
OH, MY GOD!
SHE JUST--
CAN SOMEBODY
CALL THE PARAMEDICS?
CALL THE POLICE!
YOU HAD A PHOTO
IN GRIFFITH PARK.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW, CUTE, CUTE, CUTE!
KIND OF LOOKS,
LIKE, A LITTLE SLUTTY THOUGH.
YOU NEED TO WORK
ON YOUR PRESENCE.
I DIDN'T FEEL THAT YOU EMBRA--
OH, MY GOD!
(gasps)
SHE'S OUT OF IT.
SOMEBODY CALL
THE PARAMEDICS.
I'M CALLING 911.
SHE JUST NEEDS HER...
(gasps)
OKAY, SHE'S BLINKING.
SHE'S OKAY.
WHEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENS,
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE
IT JUST HAPPENED.
I MEAN, BECCA--
SHE'S EXPLAINED TO ME
THAT SHE HAS
A PREEXISTING CONDITION
WHERE SHE COLLAPSES.
SHE HAS HAD TESTS DONE
SINCE SHE WAS 3 YEARS OLD,
BUT IT'S BEEN SIX OR SEVEN YEARS
SINCE HER LAST COLLAPSE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE SCARED?
ME TOO.
I WAS REALLY,
REALLY SCARED.
THE PARAMEDICS--
THEY TOOK REBECCA
TO THE HOSPITAL,
AND SHE'S OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
CONTINUE WITH JUDGING,
IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH EVERYBODY.
OKAY, SO, EVERYBODY,
JUST TAKE A... (inhales)
(exhales)
WE ARE GOING TO RESUME
WITH TATIANA.
SO YOU HAD TO WORK
A BROWN POTATO SACK
LIKE IT WAS
A $20,000 COUTURE GOWN.
YOU WERE WALKING LIKE
EACH FOOT WEIGHS A TON.
BE LIGHT ON YOUR FEET.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN GRIFFITH PARK, AND YOU HAD
TO CONTROL FLOWERS,
A FINE MAN IN THE BACKGROUND
AND TEN DOGS.
BEAUTIFUL.
GORGEOUS FACE.
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
STEPHANIE SEYMOUR
MEETS JACQUELINE BISSET.
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE TIFFANY.
WHEN YOU WERE GOING
DOWN THE STAIRS,
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU NEEDED
A CANE OR A WALKER.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO STAIRMASTER
WITH YOUR HEELS ON.
WOW, GOOD CONFIDENCE.
CLOSE UP, PLEASE.
OOH.
A LITTLE CHEROKEE INDIAN,
A LITTLE BLACK GIRL,
A LITTLE CHINESE GIRL,
A LITTLE SPANISH GIRL...
THE EYES ARE BEAUTIFUL.
I'M LOVING IT.
SARAH.
I'M SORRY,
BUT YOU WERE WALKING
LIKE THE FUNKY CHICKEN.
YOUR HEAD KEPT BOBBING.
YOU ARE NOT A FASHION MODEL
ON THE RUNWAY.
YOU HAD SUCH NERVOUS ENERGY.
I SAW EVERY "OH, MY GOD"
ALL OVER YOUR FACE
AND ALL OVER YOUR BODY.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT'S NOT POUNCING OUT
AT ME ENOUGH.
HER BODY ISN'T STRONG.
I DON'T FEEL THE CONFIDENCE
IN THE OVERALL PHOTO.
CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP?
- FACE IS BEAUTIFUL.
- YEAH.
YOU HAVE THAT VERY
OLD-FASHIONED KIND OF BEAUTY.
- SHE DOES.
- NEXT WE HAVE LLUVY.
YOU WERE THE ONLY GIRL
THAT DID SOMETHING
WITH THAT SACK.
TO ME IT WASN'T A SACK ANYMORE,
IT WAS A DRESS.
I WAS LIKE,
"OOH, I WANT TO BUY THAT."
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GIVING
MORE OF A SEXY CHIHUAHUA WALK
THAN A REAL FASHION WALK.
YOUR PERSONALITY IS
IMPORTANT, BUT DON'T LET IT
OVERSHADOW WHAT YOU HAVE ON.
GORGEOUS!
YEAH. LOOKS FIERCE.
ALL RIGHT, LLUVY. THANK YOU.
MICHELLE.
THERE WAS NOTHING POSITIVE
ABOUT THAT WALK WHATSOEVER.
TO ME, YOU LOOKED LIKE
YOU'RE MODELING FOR THE FARMERS
IN THE POTATO FACTORY--
LIKE, "HERE'S THE NEW SACK!
Y'ALL WANT THIS.
THESE HOLD 50 POTATOES."
FIERCE.
- WOW.
- LOOK AT THAT EYE.
IT'S, LIKE, ON THE SIDE
OF YOUR HEAD LIKE AN ANTELOPE.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS
LIKE AN INSULT,
BUT NO, THAT IS AMAZING.
THAT'S WHAT MODELS ARE.
MODELS ARE WEIRD.
THEY'RE DIFFERENT,
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES THAT PHOTO
SO AMAZINGLY GORGEOUS.
BRANDY.
I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT COME DOWN
THE END OF THE RUNWAY
AND ACTUALLY SMACK ME
IN THE FACE.
YOU LOOK PISSED OFF.
THERE'S A MODEL ANGRY,
AND THERE'S A...
YOU HAD THAT KIND OF...
(grunts)
YOU ANGRY, GIRL.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
- YES.
- OOH.
THE OVERALL SHAPE
OF THE FACE IS BEAUTIFUL...
GORGEOUS.
- BUT THERE'S SOMETHING--
- THERE'S NO PASSION
IN THE EYES,
I DON'T THINK.
CHRISTINA.
YOUR HAIR GOT CAUGHT
ON YOUR LIP,
AND YOU LEFT IT THERE.
SOMETHING GETS CAUGHT,
AS A MODEL, YOU GO, LIKE...
AND JUST KEEP IT GOING.
WORK IT, LIKE,
"I KNEW IT WAS THERE."
WORK IT OUT,
THAT'S IT, GIRL.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
- THE FACE IS BORING.
- IT'S NOT BORING.
YOU'RE QUITE BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU'RE NOT BRINGING IT
FROM WITHIN.
NAIMA.
WORK ON YOUR TURN.
THANK YOU. VERY WEIRD.
YOU'RE GONNA KNOCK
OTHER MODELS LIKE SKITTLES
ACROSS THE RUNWAY
WITH A TURN LIKE THAT.
OKAY.
- OH.
- THIS IS MODERN.
I LIKE THE BENT FOOT.
IT DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
- ME EITHER.
- IT WORKS FOR ME.
- AND ME.
- OKAY, THERE WE GO.
- AND HIM.
- AND ME.
SOLD.
BRITTANY.
FIRST OF ALL, I SEE
FOUNDATION FROM HERE.
MAKES YOU NOT LOOK LIKE
A NEW, FRESH MODEL,
LIKE A PALETTE.
YOUR WALK WAS WAY TOO HEAVY,
KIND OF LIKE A HORSE
GRAZING IN A PASTURE.
THAT'S SO FUNNY.
YOU WALK LIKE YOU'RE
IN A ROCK CLUB
WITH A BOTTLE OF BEER
IN YOUR HAND, LIKE...
PUT A LITTLE BIT
MORE FASHION INTO IT.
OKAY.
GREAT MAKEUP, GREAT HAIR.
SLAMMIN'.
BUT THEN YOU GO
TO THE CLOSE...
IT LOOKS LIKE
A PORNO COVER TO ME.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE
A HIGH-CLASS PORNO,
THE ONES THAT COST $39.95--
HOW DO I KNOW THAT?
I THINK IT'S
THE PINK LIPSTICK ALSO.
NOELLE.
YOU SEEM UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH YOUR FOOTING.
YOU REALLY NEED
TO TURN IT UP.
YOU ARE THIS PRETTY
GIRL NEXT DOOR.
WE'RE LOOKING
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOOK AT THESE LEGS.
THAT'S AMAZING.
YOUR LEGS LOOK LONGER
THAN ALL THE GIRLS BEHIND YOU.
THIS IS A GREAT SHOT
ALL AROUND.
NOW, WHO WOULD HAVE
KNOWN THAT THIS PEDESTRIAN
WOULD PULL OFF
FRENCH "VOGUE"?
KAHLEN, NOW, NOTICE
YOUR RIGHT ARM IS PARALYZED.
YOU NEED TO KIND OF
WAKE IT UP.
GIVE IT A JOLT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
THE NECK LOOKS CROOKED.
I DON'T LIKE THE NECK SO MUCH,
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE STIFF.
LOOKS A LITTLE
BARBIE-DOLLISH.
THANKS, KAYLEN.
KEENYAH.
ALMOST STUMBLED,
AND YOU KEPT GOING...
YOU DID.
AND I THOUGHT THAT
YOU HAVE GREAT LEGS.
YOU WALK LIKE A PRO.
YOU REBOUNDED.
I FELT LIKE YOUR ENERGY
IS A LITTLE BIT BORING.
BRING IT UP A NOTCH.
AND, CHILD, THIS OUTFIT--
WHAT'S GOING ON, BABY?
SHE'S GOT POTPOURRI
OF THE PANTS AND CARNIVAL TOP.
I UNDERSTAND IF YOU GOT
A LITTLE WASTED ONE NIGHT,
AND MAYBE YOUR BOYFRIEND
WAS DOODLING
ON YOUR BUTT OR SOMETHING.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY SIMPLE--
JEANS AND A WIFE BEATER.
JUST... (grunts).
LOOK HOW SLIM AND LONG
THE BODY LOOKS.
THAT IS A TOTAL
EDITORIAL ADVERTISING SHOT.
WHOA.
THIS IS THE FIRST CLICK
OF THE PHOTOGRAPHER'S CAMERA.
MAKES UP FOR THE OUTFIT.
IT'S THE BEST BEAUTY SHOT
OF THE LOT.
NOW IT'S TIME TO DELIBERATE.
- LLUVY.
- THIS PHOTOGRAPH SAVES HER.
SHE'S ABSOLUTELY SLAMMING.
MICHELLE.
SHE HAS NO STAGE PRESENCE
WHATSOEVER.
SHE REMINDS ME
OF A MAGIC 8 BALL--
YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET.
- NOELLE.
- NOELLE, IN THIS SHOT,
IS SO ADORABLE.
- KEENYAH.
- THIS GIRL KNOCKS MY SOCKS OFF.
IN PERSON,
KEENYAH LOOKS SECOND-RATE.
SARAH.
THIS GIRL SHOULD BE
ON A PIRATE FLAG.
I THINK YOU GUYS AREN'T
SEEING THE BEAUTY
IN SARAH'S BONE STRUCTURE.
HER PICTURE FROM LAST WEEK
WAS ONE OF THE STRONGEST.
- TIFFANY.
- BEAUTIFUL BODY, GREAT FACE,
INCREDIBLE BONE STRUCTURE.
YOU CAN'T DENY
THE PICTURE IS FIERCE.
THE PICTURE DOESN'T LIE.
- NAIMA.
- I LOVE THIS PICTURE OF NAIMA.
SHE'S NOT GONNA BE
EVERYBODY'S CUP OF TEA,
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES
NAIMA VERY SPECIAL.
TATIANA.
I REALLY DON'T LIKE
THIS LITTLE GIRL TATIANA.
HER FACE SEEMS A LITTLE SMALL
TO ME, A LITTLE CRUNCHED.
I HAVE TO DISAGREE.
I THINK TATIANA
IS REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
BRITTANY.
I RESENT THAT YOU THINK
THAT THIS WOMAN LOOKS LIKE ME.
SHE LOOKS SO MUCH
LIKE YOU, JANICE.
THE DOG LOOKS LIKE ME
IN THIS PICTURE, THE PIT BULL.
IN EVERY SHOT, SHE ENDS UP
LOOKING LIKE A PORN STAR.
- BRITTANY IS OUT.
- KAHLEN.
SHE NEEDS TO TURN IT OUT
AND BECOME A TOP MODEL,
NOT A GIRL WHO JUST CAME
OFF THE FLOWER TRUCK.
- CHRISTINA.
- CHRISTINA WITH THE CRAZY,
MANIC EYES--
IN THIS PICTURE,
THE DOG LICKING ITS LIPS
IS THE BEST THING.
STOP.
SHE'S COLD,
SHE'S KIND OF FISHY,
BUT SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
SHE'S IN.
BRANDY.
BRANDY, YOU NEED TO TURN
YOURSELF INTO HOT TODDY.
BEAUTIFUL SKIN COLOR,
BEAUTIFUL BONE STRUCTURE.
WITH THAT PERSONALITY,
SHE ISN'T GOING ANYWHERE.
- REBECCA.
- SHE LOOKS SCARED.
SHE'S MISSING AN ARM.
THE FLOWERS
LOOK LIKE A TAIL.
REBECCA'S NOT NECESSARILY
MY FAVORITE TYPE OF MODEL.
SHE TENDS TO BE
A LITTLE BIT SAFE-LOOKING.
BUT WHEN SHE PHOTOGRAPHS,
SHE'S NOT SAFE.
REBECCA IS GONNA
BE OUT FOR ME.
THINGS WENT WELL,
AND THE DOCTOR WAS GREAT.
I'VE HAD PROBLEMS WITH THIS
EVER SINCE I WAS 3 YEARS OLD.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE VAGUS NERVE
IN YOUR BODY--
SOMETIMES CONNECTIONS
KIND OF GO HAYWIRE.
IT'S NOT
A LIFE-AND-DEATH CONDITION.
IT'S JUST A VERY INCONVENIENT,
SCARY THING.
WHEN I GOT BACK
FROM THE EMERGENCY ROOM,
I WAS ABSOLUTELY SCARED
THAT SINCE I WASN'T THERE,
I WAS GOING TO BE
THE ONE ELIMINATED.
- YOU'RE SURE YOU'RE OKAY?
- MM-HMM.
- DO YOU WANT TO CONTINUE?
- MORE THAN ANYTHING.
- YOU SURE?
- YES.
OKAY, IF AT ANY TIME
YOU FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE,
YOU JUST SIT DOWN, OKAY?
DON'T FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE BEING SO JUDGED,
AND YOU CAN'T JUST LISTEN
TO WHAT YOUR BODY IS DOING.
- OKAY.
- OKAY?
THANK YOU SO MUCH, TYRA.
I CAN'T EVEN EXPLAIN
HOW THANKFUL I FELT
THAT I WASN'T CUT YET.
I HAVE 13 BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 12 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE 12 PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE YOUNG LADIES
THAT WILL CONTINUE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
KEENYAH.
CONGRATULATIONS, KEENYAH.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
TATIANA.
REBECCA.
YOU SCARED ALL OF US
SO MUCH TONIGHT, REBECCA.
I KNOW. I'M SO SORRY.
BUT I ADMIRE YOUR TENACITY,
AND I ADMIRE YOU RETURNING.
AND SO I WANT YOU
TO TAKE THIS PICTURE,
AND THEN I WANT YOU TO SIT.
TIFFANY.
LLUVY.
CONGRATULATIONS, LLUVY.
THANK YOU.
NAIMA.
CHRISTINA.
BRANDY.
FOUR PHOTOS LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I AM
GOING TO CALL--
NOELLE.
MICHELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
KAHLEN.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL BRITTANY AND SARAH
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR LOFT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
BRITTANY, YOUR SEXUALITY
IS WAY TOO STRONG,
AND NOT JUST SO STRONG
WHERE IT'S A VICTORIA'S SECRET
KIND OF STRONG.
WE'RE THINKING IT'S GETTING
A LITTLE TRIPLE-X
FOR THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
SARAH.
WE FEEL YOU MELTING.
WE SEE
SUCH A STRONG FACE.
WE WONDER IF THIS GIRL
CAN SEE HER LOVELINESS,
IF SHE BELIEVES IN IT.
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE,
WE DON'T BELIEVE.
BRITTANY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
OH, MY GOD,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SOMEONE WASHED THEIR FACE,
AND IT LOOKS
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SARAH.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE
A LOT MORE NATURAL TALENT
THAN A FEW OF THE GIRLS
THAT ARE STILL IN THERE.
AND YOU GOT, LIKE,
BRITTANY NEXT TO ME,
LIKE, PORN PRINCESS.
HIGH FASHION MODEL?
I DON'T THINK SO.
PLEASE.
DON'T MAKE ME VOMIT.
I'LL BE OKAY.
ALL MY LIFE,
I GREW UP THE UGLY DUCKLING,
AND ONCE AGAIN,
I'VE PROVEN TO MYSELF
THAT I'M NOT GOOD ENOUGH,
AND IT'S JUST HARD.
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
WHEN THE GIRLS' GRACE UNDER
PRESSURE IS PUT TO THE TEST...
AAH! I CAN'T HIT IT!
DON'T ACT.
SOME OF 'EM ARE LIKE THAT,
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
BRANDY LOSES HER COOL.
YOU SHUT UP.
I WASN'T TALKING TO YOU.
WHILE TIFFANY LETS LOOSE.
ALL OF Y'ALL BITCHES EVIL.